[Applause]
thank you very much
good afternoon my name is annette taylor
i am a wife
mother
air force veteran and retired union
letter carrier
i delivered mail for
thank you
i delivered mail for 32 years as a proud
member of the national association of
letter
carriers service to our communities and
service to our country that is the
spirit of letter carriers
in recent years while our folks have
delivered mail and other essential
parcels and packages during the copen 19
epidemic pandemic we've confronted
instability and uncertainty just as our
patrons and customers have
they longed for better circumstances and
so did we
nalc is proud to have contributed to the
efforts over the 12 years 12 years that
resulted in this bipartisan legislation
that brings us together today
this legislation will help position the
united states postal service to provide
the service that the american people
deserve
the late congressman elijah cummings my
friend and fellow marylander
worked relentlessly for many years to
pass postal reform legislation
today his efforts will be rewarded
thanks to president biden
and bipartisan support
[Applause]
mr president the postal service is an
essential facilitator of our democracy
and our economy
we know there is more to do to secure
long-term viability but today is a huge
step forward
thank you for backing american workers
my union stands ready to assist you god
bless you and thank you for signing this
bill
[Applause]
you know annette as you were speaking
look down at uh
senator carper used to be chairman of
this committee
how many years tommy you working on this
[Laughter]
i tell you what
your service both in the air force as
the letter carrier
is real and it's all about serving your
community and i appreciate it very much
matter of fact when i said it's good to
meet you she said
i know you we met before and i said i
apologize she said you used to show up
every in wilmington
how often
oh in d.c
every year i'd show up the letter
carriers breakfast or lunch or dinner i
remember which
but um it reminded me why i
i think foreign policy is easier
war and peace goes down easier jerry i
think
i
senator peters senator portman senator
carper senator tillis
representatives maloney comer conley
and virginia foxx and
steven lynch stevie good to see you pal
i didn't do you i didn't know you did
post offices
uh no
no and uh and brendan lawrence who
served the u.s postal service uh for 30
years before being elected to congress
which was harder
well look um
some of you know before i became
president
i'm sure you all know this i was the ben
franklin professor of practice at the
university of pennsylvania professor jim
you know
and everybody walks in they wonder why
ben franklin's pictures hanging on my
portraits hanging in my office
because if i didn't put that off
there'd be no nobody i knew would get
into university of pennsylvania again
i'm only kidding that's a joke
but ben franklin one of our founding
fathers was our first postmaster general
and he saw the postal service
in a way to connect the colonies and to
build together
as one nation i mean literally that's
what it was seen as it was to connect
the colonies and build one nation
connect everything
he saw the power of the postal service
to deliver more than the mail but some
of our most basic freedoms and basic
rights were delivered by the post office
freedom of speech by allowing citizens
to voice
and to their voices to be amplified all
across the country
freedom of the press
by offering
discounted rates for newspapers
the right to privacy by expressly
prohibiting this sounds silly but
expressly prohibiting the opening of
mail that belong to somebody else
and beyond those rights and freedoms our
oldest postal roads helped give rises
some of our nation's most essential
infrastructure there are coastal
highways that's why a lot of these roads
were built to provide post and by the
way
we used to serve with a guy who was
from west virginia jennings randolph
and uh he uh the thing he he started an
airline but the way the airlines used to
work was there'd be a great tommy they
put up two big poles like goal post and
they would put a wire between it and
they'd hang whatever the post of service
the post mail used to be collected and
the airplane would come down with a hook
on it and pick it up and take it off so
you know
i'm not going to say if jenny's were
here you'd say there'd be no there'd be
no post office out of there but anyway
i'm only kidding but
but today more than 670 thousands 75 000
dedicated women to men
of the u.s postal service continue to
deliver for the american people they
keep us healthy by shipping four million
prescriptions per day four million
per day
and when we're dedicated uh
when we uh and when we dedicate it to
the to send and committed we would send
to uh to free uh to covet 19 tests
directly to people's
homes the postal service stepped up to
make that happen as well
and now they've delivered over 200 and
300 320 million
coveted test 19 kits so far in every
state territory and us military base in
the world
impressive turnaround or an
unprecedented task it's continuing to
truly heroic service that they provided
throughout this pandemic
when everyone was worried about the
supply chain delays would ruin the
holidays the post office delivered the
packages that were that
more than any other shipper in the world
and they got the gifts to our homes and
our loved ones on time
the postal service is central to our
economy and essential to rural america
delivering mail and packages between
small businesses and customers every
single solitary day
and the deliveries uh you know and and
delivering seeds and even live animals
often the parts of the country that
private carriers can't or won't or
aren't required to reach
and there's another essential thing the
postal service delivers your vote
in 2020 43 of the votes cast by ballot
were cast by mail
and on average it took those ballots
[Applause]
on average it took those ballots less
than two days to get from the voters to
the election office faster than the
average delivery time for first class
mail
so it's no exaggeration to say that the
postal service delivers democracy
there's no exaggeration to say the
postal service is essential as it ever
was has ever been today
in 2006 the law required postal service
to pre-pay prepay retirement benefits 50
years into the future
no other no other company or federal
agency has do anything like that
and uh
requirement of that law stretch the
postal services finances almost the
breaking point
with real consequences
there are stories of people across the
country getting hit with late fees
because their credit card bill arrived a
week late if it arrived at all small
businesses on the verge of collapse
because payments they were counting on
were were severely delayed elderly
americans suffering because they had to
go weeks without their medication
i like many of you made a campaign
promise to fix this and today we are you
all the members in front of me did all
the work
uh i made the promise you did all the
work
um
and i'm glad that strong bipartisan
majorities in the house and senate have
come together to deliver on this needed
reform
with this bill we're repealing the
pre-funding mandate
and setting the postal service on a more
sustainable and stable financial footing
we're guaranteeing that the mail will
continue to be delivered six days a week
and the bill increases transparency by
requiring the postal service to develop
online and online public dashboard
updated weekly with local and national
service performance data
you'll be able to see in real time how
well the postal service is delivering
for you and for your community
and this bill streamlines health care
for postal workers as well
they deliver for us so through rain and
snow and sleet and we're making sure
that health care they need will be there
for them as well
and finally this bill will allow the
postal service to partner with state
local and tribal governments to offer
valuable and helpful non-postal services
to the public
imagine a trip to the post office where
you can pick up your bus pass or your
hunting license or your fishing license
of course there are more areas where we
want to see the postal service leading
for example
it needs to do more to modernize and
electrify its fleet of vehicles to
reduce greenhouse gas emissions and to
save money
we're going to do that
and i'll continue to fight for these
common sense improvements but today we
enshrine in law
our recognition that the postal service
is fundamental to our economy
to our democracy to our health and the
very sense of who we are as a nation
and this bill this bill recognizes the
postal service as a public service and
we're ensuring that it can continue to
serve all americans for generations to
come i'll now go over and sign that
postal bill and those of you who are
going to come up while i sign it i'm not
going to read out your names they told
me who you are everybody miss denny can
come
i'm kidding stenny
and we'll get this reform bill finally
signed and tommy it only took what 11
years
12 12 12 years
rob and that's that's pretty fast right
anyway all kidding aside thank you for
the hard work you've done you've done a
good job
[Applause]
by the way
[Music]
all right it's official all right
just
anyway
[Music]
yes
yes
[Music]
oh
[Music]
all right
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
easy
[Music]
get out
thank you
[Music]
yes
[Music]
now
[Music]
yes
please
this
[Music]
congratulations
yes
okay
huh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
thank
i
hey
this is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
what's up
[Music]
um
um
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i recognized
[Music]
yes
oh
let's
oh
hey
yes
[Music]
thank
family
hello
[Music]
oh
okay
[Music]
um
cheers
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
mr president
mr president are you worried at all
about kobe coming back
his name is fun for copenhagen
are you worried about ea ii
[Music]
yes